el campo de la economía se basa
enteramente en el concepto de escasez y
de hecho no necesitaríamos el campo de
la economía si no existiera la idea de
escasez en el mundo es significa escasez
pensemos en su significado cotidiano
quiere decir que no hay suficiente
cantidad de algo cuando hablamos de
bienes servicios o recursos escasos
hablamos de cosas que las personas
usarían en cantidades superiores a las
realmente existentes si no tuvieran un
costo asociado en este vídeo vamos a
hablar sobre algunos bienes servicios y
recursos y a preguntarnos si estos son
escasos o no una idea relacionada con la
escasez es su opuesto la noción de un
recurso de libre uso algo que podríamos
decir es infinitamente abundante o algo
que dentro de cierto contexto es tan
abundante que da la impresión de que se
puede tener tanto como se quiera de este
una persona puede tener mucho de ese
algo sin que a otra persona le falte la
razón por la que la escasez es esencial
en la economía
es porque la economía estudia la forma
en que se distribuyen dichos recursos
escasos si hay más demanda por esos
recursos comparada con la cantidad que
existe de éstos quien nos recibe en qué
cantidad y que tienen que dar a cambio
de dichos recursos escasos para el
propósito de este vídeo primero vamos a
asegurarnos de tener una buena idea de
cuáles recursos son escasos y cuáles no
y por qué esta es una imagen de cambiar
que esencialmente son huevas de pescado
y no es fácil de conseguir estas huevas
de pescado se encuentran en lo profundo
del agua y alguien tiene que ir a
conseguirlas también necesitan empacarse
de cierta manera para llegar a la mesa
qué piensan ustedes que el caviar es un
recurso escaso o un recurso de libre uso
si fuera un recurso de libre uso
estaríamos rodeados de caviar sería tan
abundante que podríamos comerlo hasta
hartarnos y alcanzaría para que todos
comieran lo que quisieran claramente ese
no es el caso el caviar es un recurso
escaso de hecho es bastante escaso y es
por esa razón que sí
en consumirlo tienen que pagar mucho
para tenerlo esta es la imagen de
algunas personas trabajando en una
fábrica el recurso que vemos aquí es la
mano de obra la mano de obra es
interesante porque no es tan tangible
como el caviar pero sigue siendo un
recurso de hecho podríamos decir que la
escasez del caviar se debe en mucho a la
falta de mano de obra para obtenerlo
aquí claramente vemos a algunos
caballeros que están trabajando con
telas ustedes consideran la mano de obra
un recurso escaso o un recurso de libre
uso sería un recurso de libre uso si las
personas estuvieran dispuestas a
trabajar todo el tiempo para otras
personas incluso un número infinito de
horas algo que humanamente no sería
posible y aunque lo fuera las personas
no están dispuestas a trabajar por gusto
todo el tiempo para otras personas
siempre quieren algo a cambio así que de
nuevo es un recurso escaso
en esta imagen vemos muchos recursos
este hermoso pueblo a orillas de este
lago tranquilo así que aquí vemos
recursos escasos
muchas personas quisieran tener una
vista como la que tienen desde esta casa
u hotel y muchas personas quisieran
vivir ahí debido a esta hermosa vista
pero no todos pueden vivir ahí esto es
un recurso escaso el agua del lago es
algo interesante puedo imaginar que hace
mucho tiempo antes de que existiera este
pueblo las personas que vivieron a
orillas del lago lo veían como un
recurso de libre uso si alguien de ese
entonces sentía sed podría ir
directamente al lago a beber de él sin
tener que dar nada a cambio pero quizá
ahora este lago sea un recurso escaso al
menos en cierta medida quizá quieran
preservarlo por diversas razones y para
llevar el agua a las casas seguro se
necesitan bienes servicios y mano de
obra para instalar las tuberías y
purificar el agua durante la mayor parte
de la historia humana el aire es
considerado un recurso de libre uso
incluso ahora se considera al aire
como un recurso de libre uso cuando
alguien respira hondo
no afecta nuestra habilidad de respirar
hondo también no nos quita el aire a
nosotros existe una cantidad infinita de
aire en nuestra atmósfera no pero para
nuestros propósitos lo percibimos como
si fuera algo infinito pero si
desaparecieran las plantas
fotosintéticas o si comenzara a
disminuir el aire que podemos respirar o
si estuviéramos en la estación espacial
internacional en donde hay una cantidad
finita de aire entonces podríamos
imaginarlo como un recurso escaso
podríamos imaginar alguna colonia en la
luna o en marte o en el espacio en donde
tengan un tipo de sistema económico que
decida quién recibe qué cantidad de aire
por el momento dejamos esto así la
escasez es la idea esencial de la
economía y es su razón de existir y
conforme avancemos en el estudio de la
micro y la macroeconomía veremos formas
de asignar o utilizar estos recursos
escasos y estudiaremos qué es lo que
tienen que dar las personas para tener
acceso a estos recursos también veremos
modelos
ayuden a comprender cuáles son las
implicaciones de los diversos métodos
para asignar recursos y con esto
terminamos